that includes rallies in six states over
the next
three days tony thank you very much in
fact joe biden and president trump both
have ambitious plans to get their
messages out in this the last week
before election day both are heavily
focused on battleground states as well
biden is working to expand his support
while the president
appears to be focusing on his base
including in the must win
state of pennsylvania ed o'keefe now
reports
thank you very much president trump made
three stops in pennsylvania on monday a
state needs to win again
in order to win the white house down
seven points to joe biden the president
made yet another explicit appeal to the
state's
suburban female voters they'll
confiscate your guns
terminate religious liberty and destroy
the suburbs
women of the suburbs you must love me i
can tell you
and the president slammed his opponent
this election is a choice
between a trump super recovery
or a biden super depression
but biden struck back in a surprise
visit to suburban philadelphia
the bottom line is donald trump is the
worst possible president
the worst possible person to try to lead
us through this pandemic
as the president made multiple stops in
pennsylvania and is traveling
far more frequently biden faced
questions about his lighter travel
schedule
i'm going to be going to iowa i'm going
to wisconsin i'm going to georgia i'm
going to florida
and maybe other places as well reason
why it looks like
we're not traveling we're not putting on
super spreaders
meanwhile as the trump campaign pushes
to increase support among
african americans the president's
son-in-law and top adviser jared kushner
is facing criticism
for seeming to suggest that black
americans don't want to succeed
one thing we've seen in a lot of the the
the black community which is mostly
democrat is that
president trump's policies are the
policies that can help people break out
of the problems that they're complaining
about
but he can't want them to be successful
more than they want to be successful
the white house said the comments were
being taken out of context
as you heard biden say there he's headed
to georgia today for what his campaign
says is another speech
on the topic of national unity the fact
that he's in georgia at all is a signal
that democrats believe they can win back
the peach state for the first time
since 1992 similar to that visit he's
making later this week to iowa
state where he's running even with the
president it's a place they didn't
expect to be
his running mate kamala harris heads
later this week to arizona
and then texas to other republican
leaning states